this presentation is delivered by the
Stanford center for professional
development
welcome everybody back for the fall for
the 23rd year of the Stanford seminar on
people computers and design
I'm Scott clemmer I'll be your host this
fall and I'm extremely excited to
announce that our speaker today is Scott
snippy I asked Scott this summer if he
could come speak in the fall and I asked
him in particular I said could you come
the first week because I think he'd be a
really great kick off speaker and and
I'd like to tell you why I met Scott in
the late 90s when he was working on new
kinds of haptic user interfaces and
Scott has long been one of my role
models in terms of somebody who's been
able to have a creative research thread
and product thread for his whole life
and each decade he does something new
and interesting so when I met him he was
working on computer animated films and
haptic user interfaces at a secret think
tank on Page Mill Road called interval
research after that he moved on and
started his own studio producing
artistic installations that have been
shown worldwide and a number of
galleries and in the years since he's
moved on to a number of different
platforms not only has he worked with
folks like Bjork in for her latest
Biophilia album but when the iPhone iPad
came out he published an interesting
article called why art wants to be 99
cents and so he's been thinking about
new platforms for interactive media for
a long time and Scott's put together
some of his thinking on this issue that
he's going to share with us today
thanks a lot it's it's a pleasure to be
here and you guys are so lucky to have
Terry and Scott and and Jeff as as
people to work with they're really
they're really unique and outstanding in
their field as people who combined a
complete view of you know humanity
technology and creativity all at once
there's very few people I know like like
you guys so it's always an honor to get
to come here and and speak in in this
setting so to explain a little bit Who I
am I've if there was a big company I
could work in to do what I do I kind of
wish I could but there's there still
isn't so I ended up starting a couple of
companies on my own one's called snippy
interactive that produces interactive
gestural experiences and the other is
called snippy studio that makes
interactive apps primarily music apps
and you know it's interesting I keep my
whole light like Scott mentioned I've
kind of struggled in my life trying to
figure out how to express new ideas in
culture that are that are somewhere
between you know art art and technology
and like like you just humanity hit
communication and I think I've come
especially in the last few years to
believe that at least in today's culture
in the West maybe starting a company is
potentially like the most creative
activity you can do it seems like you
can the idea of what a product is has
radically changed especially in the last
few years where all of a sudden things
that would have been called you know
works of art instillation crazy etc are
now like viable business models
especially you know around here so it's
a very very exciting time and I'm and
for those of you who are just kind of
graduating into it I think it's it's
especially nice because you can avoid I
think a lot of pain of the time before
when when there wasn't a such an easy
Avenue for the expression of strange
ideas so I like to begin just talking a
little bit about our perception I think
often we forget some of us may have
never even thought about it that none of
us actually perceive reality but we
rather
construct a model of reality in our
brains from five time varying sense
streams right so our current consensual
view of reality it's only one of an
infinite array of those possible to
perceive with this sensory apparatus
that we have and I think we often also
forget that we do have a sixth sense
that that the brain isn't just an
integrator but there's also it's also a
sixth sense generator of sense stimuli
and we have access to alternate
realities when we dream when we huh
loosen ate when we imagine and when we
perceive works of art so most of my
career has been an interest in finding
time-based I guess you call them like
super stimuli that produce alternate
perceptual realities in our brains I got
really excited about computers you know
as soon as I saw them and realize it was
a way to to create a billion other forms
of reality in addition to the one that
we ordinarily see you know with with our
eyes and touch with our fingertips so
I'd like to show a few examples on
something really troubling has happened
in in culture in the last 10 years is
that may I bit you know the reference
Scott but the the window of references
in scientific publications and also in
the news and so on has now shrunk to ten
years where there used to be like a
longer tail is that do you know about
this where yeah and so so when I give a
talk I like to talk of particular
influence --is I think that our benefit
to anybody interested in human-computer
interaction and they're mostly come from
the Arts does anybody know what this
images by any chance ok that's good and
I have my my time is not wasted here so
this is a work of art called a Cornell
box this one was made in 1940 what's
interesting is that it's about the size
of an iPad and it's interactive it's a
little box that's filled with stuff I
particularly like this one because as a
musical paper in the background it has
sand it has a pearl and you actually
play around with it but it's not you
know useful in any ordinary sense the
purpose is just to
give you an alternate interactive
reality that you dive into Joseph
Cornell was a surrealist he was the only
kind of accepted member of the
surrealist movement from the United
States and I was lucky because my
parents were artists and they introduced
me to works like this when I was quite
young and I really wanted to make stuff
like that you know we had a workshop
when I was growing up and I would make
things like this out of plastic where
you'd put you know sand and other types
other things inside of it but you know
interactivity isn't merely with
computers it's not just digital
interactivity there's ways of making
kind of mechanical forms of
interactivity by the way have any of you
any of you read count zero though the
William Gibson novel that's uh yeah I
guess there's a there's an interesting
footnote about Cornell boxes because in
that in that that book is about the kind
of unleashing of artificial intelligence
it's a future where artificial
intelligences are throttled and this one
finds a way of breaking out and then it
lives on the space station surrounding
the earth and the whole the whole plot
of the novel hinges around trying to
figure out where these counterfeit
Cornell boxes are coming from somehow
these they're very valuable even today
they're very valuable so they're finding
counterfeit Cornell box is for sale and
galleries and the whole novel is
tracking down where they're coming from
and it turns out that that's what this
artificial intelligence is making it it
has this big space with tons of just
garbage spinning around in a space
station and given like massively more
into more intelligence than human beings
have what this artificial intelligence
has chose to do is to make Cornell boxes
all day long so it's possible that's the
highest achievement of intelligence is
to sit around making these kind of digs
of course there's other ways of
accessing alternate realities I
particularly like these two because
they're you know touch screens one is
this through the looking-glass right the
that a mirror is a touch screen and I
think it's maybe it's the first one we
discover you have a young daughter now
and I notice you know that an incredible
fascination with mirrors and I think you
know through literature and Bert but
particularly in
a lookingglass there's a fascination of
what's what's behind that screen there's
also a film on on next to that image is
a still from a film called Orpheus by
Jean Cocteau again I was lucky because
my parents were so weird so my dad took
me to see this movie when I was like 16
and if you like the matrix you'll really
love this movie because many maybe all
of the ideas in the matrix actually come
from this movie but they were done in
this very practical scrappy way because
they didn't have digital special effects
in fact they didn't even use optical
special effects everything in the movie
is done practically through sort of
clever tricks of materials so plunging
through a mirror as in this scene was
done by filling a pool with mercury and
then filming it sideways and having
someone wear gloves you can see
carefully if you look carefully a
person's wearing gloves and you know
moving dipping into that mirror so for
me this was the ultimate looking glass
you know when I was when I was 10 years
old I was introduced to an Apple 2
computer and the the neat thing about
computers in those days as you turn them
on and all you had was a flashing cursor
and a manual of how to write Basic
programming so there you know now we
have this maker culture reemerging but
back in the day with these computers
there was nothing to do except write
code and what what struck me about the
computer screen you know even then when
I was like 10 years old was that this
was it's not like a typewriter it's more
like a movie screen and that on the
screen of a computer you have an
infinite infinitely varying plane of
light time varying light and color right
so anything is possible on the computer
screen and it's really really important
to remember that now because we've we've
pushed so many metaphors
some of them like very very boring
metaphors like a desktop metaphor onto
something that has an infinite potential
and I think if there's one kind of
lesson I'd love to be able to convey to
people that was obvious to those of us
when we had computers without an
interface is that you can make anything
you want on that screen it's like a
movie screen
and this is one of the programs that
that I really dug that's strange
well there you this was one of the
programs that was one of my favorite
programs when I was a kid called pinball
Construction Set let's see if it plays
weird something strange with my it's
showing it here Wow something got
corrupted I think very very weird I
might have to just tell you about it
then it's not it well let me just tell
you about it then I think it's the new
OS or something
so yes okay so let me just tell you
about this program because it's amazing
it came out in 1983 and it's a program
where you have this pinball game but it
starts up and the pinball machine is
empty and on the right is a pallet of
pinball stuff like bumpers and flippers
and you can drag any of them into the
program that you like and make any kind
of pinball you machine pinball machine
you want so the first thing I did was
put a hundred flippers in you know and
see what's what's the game like but what
that introduced me to was the idea of
like meta program that you could make a
kind of computer program or game that is
a superset of all possibilities within a
creative system you know and and there
aren't that many as many things like
that today and but it really inspired me
to maybe want to make stuff like that
okay so now let's see I hope that other
movie actually plays where it's supposed
to play so this is another program that
came out the the year after in 1984
called music Construction Set see if
that plays okay a lot of problems maybe
the HDMI thing or something I don't know
let's try again
a useful music program that was sold as
a game and it was a best-seller you know
made huge amounts of money and as soon
as I got this program I wanted to go
fill it with something so I went to the
music store and I bought sheet music for
like new order and the Beatles and The
Clash and other kind of music I liked
and they started to just understand
music by playing with it and what I
liked about this is that it kind of
tricks you into learning something like
somehow cuz I was taking music lessons
and you know I'd never practice I'd
never do my homework but then this
because it was just so fun and it wasn't
it wasn't described as education or
lessons I actually learned way more
about about music through that process
and of course this is somebody you know
all of us all of us I think are inspired
by one way or another either for either
for or against Steve Jobs so one thing I
want to discuss here is actually a
little bit a little bit of criticism but
mostly praise so when the when the Mac
first came out I think I was well even
though I was like 14 or something I was
actually one of the one of the few
people that was a little bit
disappointed with it because because of
that reason of the computer screens
potential to be anything as a little
disappointed that now the computer
screen got collapsed to be a desk like
with a trash and folders a like I
thought what's the one thing I've never
taken a picture of in my house in my
life is my desk it's like it's like the
most boring thing in in my life I mean I
get things done there but there's
nothing really that exciting or
inspiring about it so I was a little bit
disappointed and and kind of dreaming
more about cinematic interfaces which
now of course we see with the iPad like
Apple has gone to cinematic interfaces
in a way none of us could have imagined
using a language of wipes dissolves
fades and so on but the time I was a
little bit disappointed now the thing
though the bigger thing I wanted to talk
about Steve Jobs though was about
influence you know someone asked him
I've got a lot of you know this quote
but somebody asked him why have you been
so much more creative and innovative
than Bill Gates and he said well it's
it's pretty simple and it's not anything
to do with me intrinsically or my mind
my brain it's just that I took big big
sua's of my time and I did strange
things with them I took typography
classes I went to India I meditated I I
was lived in an ashram for a while and I
took acid I think he's the only CEO
who's ever advocated taking acid as the
key to innovation but I I think he's
right not necessarily about taking acid
but but that you need to fill up your
mind somehow with a lot of other stuff
outside of your field and I think even
in science I think I think there's a
read that most innovations come from
people outside of the field
you know like with DNA it came from like
x-ray crystallography in physics so
that's what I'd like to encourage people
and that's why there's sort of a long
preamble to this talk before I actually
show any of the stuff I've made because
I think it's really important to show
where it all comes from it's not just
some cool idea I had it's actually
mostly stuff that I learned from being
you know curious so this is one of the
biggest things that influenced me was
abstract film this is a film by Oscar
finger
who is the pioneered abstract animation
and you might say like what what use is
abstract animation well here's some of
it so you know what it is this is film
that he made in 1913
study number eight
and it's a way of
you see here is that there's a there's
there's a mind behind this and these are
great this is a system that you can
intuitively understand but also one that
doesn't directly Mickey Mouse music
there's a term like it's become so
standardized that the term Mickey Mouse
saying it is actually a verb that means
to just mimic in a mechanical way the
sound or you know or something else in
your life and that's exactly what you
want to avoid in making some kind of
visualization of music it's exactly the
aspects of music that you could
mechanically visualize that are the ones
that aren't interesting right so somehow
what Oscar vision is done in these films
is kind of visualize the way a human
mind interprets music right because
music is is one of the one of the
several things that doesn't exist out in
the world it only exists within our
minds and it's reconstructed because of
the peculiarities of how our brain works
the other thing is that these films are
so visually sophisticated and have a
such a sophisticated structure that I
think even for thinking about like the
layout of icons or images on a page it's
a far it's what it is it's a mature
time-based medium and human-computer
interface still may not even be the
mature time-of-use medium you know it
might be so maybe in 20 20 years or so
like we're still building that language
but people close to 100 years ago
actually matured another time-based
medium of film and I think that's an
amazing place to look for inspiration
this is another example by Alan Lai a
filmmaker that inspired me greatly and
he pioneered making films without a
camera it was quite an innovation no
people didn't really think about it for
the most part they always thought you
make a film by taking one picture over
another and he thought oh I can make a
film just by scratching drawing it
center on film so this is from my
favorite film by him called free
radicals and it's made by scratching
black leader
and especially for those of us who study
computer graphics you know we
immediately say oh did he use a computer
to do that like if something moves in 3d
you must have a you know linear algebra
behind it but it but in this case he
actually just scratched over and over
with a kind of crude in like an awl and
created this incredible sense of
movement and what I like about this type
of movement is that to me it looks like
somebody thinking the Oscar fingers work
looks like works that's composed like
you know like a music that somebody
wrote but this looks like music that
somebody improvise like like jazz so in
a way this is kind of like the Jazz of
animation this is from 1958 so there
were a number of people tried to create
instruments for for performing and the
abstraction in real time this is one
cover luma graph which is a sheet that
you press into this is one by Marcel
Duchamp who is the pioneer of conceptual
art when he made these devices called
roto reliefs where you put these discs
on it on a spinning turntable and they
have perceptual illusions color and I
like to mention some of these people
because very few people know that a
number of these like time-based artists
and filmmakers were also entrepreneurs
so Marcel Duchamp Believe It or Not
rented a spot in this in this exhibition
hall for an event called the Concorde
Lipan in Paris it's a it was an annual
trade show for inventors and he was
actually right next to the first food
processor and the first trash compactor
and he was exhibiting this which was
kind of like the first app right that's
that's like the spinning devices like
the iPhone and then these things he
could were little apps that you could
put on top of them unfortunately he
didn't sell any is completely
unsuccessful and they most of them were
destroyed but then he you know he became
quite famous later and he reproduced
these and started selling them in the
60s again you can see why it was popular
in the 60
this also something I'm sure almost none
of you know about him there's a guy
named Thomas Wilfred who built a device
called the clever locks before
television this was before television
was invented or distributed these were
available for sale he only made eighteen
and I think he only sold like three but
there were these abstract and light and
color performance devices with a little
control panel you know totally
interactive it's kind of like the first
you know Xbox or something like that and
they're really quite moving if you ever
see them this is a still from from the
image did anybody see the Tree of Life a
film by Terrence Malick some people so
there are these scenes in the movie that
are have abstract movement and color in
them I think the fairest interpretation
is that those scenes represent God
basically and I think you could make a
good point that you know this device did
a better job portraying God than like
Morgan Freeman or something the right
medium so I started experimenting like
in the 80s and the 90s with mashing up
all the stuff we didn't have that word
mash up back then but mashing up some of
these stuff that I was really passionate
about with digital computers so this was
really the first kind of polished thing
I ever made in this vein called motion
phone and it was an abstract animation
communication system so you'd have us
have a screen in this case it was you
know an SGI computer and you could move
and your movements would turn into
animation and then it's also possible to
connect to another person I'm actually
going to turn them in the sound back
here so two people at once could could
communicate and create together with
essentially an alternate form of
communication so there you see both of
us this is like $80,000 worth of
equipment and you know in 1996 or
something but what interested me is that
everybody sort of has this inside
like we all have this ability to just
move and create extremely complicated
you know alternate visual forms of
communication if you just give somebody
the right tool and of course it was
real-time that's that's what I was
really excited about is not making
something composed but making something
that you're instantly creating over and
over again and that it doesn't even
matter if you saved it it's more than
for the process of doing it that's
interesting and of course they're
finally there came a time to distribute
these these programs I'm not going to
demonstrate this one because it's quite
similar but it's available in app store
now called called motion phone and you
can actually do this now with it with
other people for you know a dollar
ninety-nine or whatever we sell it so I
started experimenting a lot with these
screen based interactive systems
particularly influenced by nature these
were the three programs called you know
bubble harp gravlax and and the answer
graph especially after I got started
showing in galleries I I tried to really
refine what I was doing so that it
didn't have any interface at all you
notice in motion phone I still had you
know buttons and sliders and so on and
that kind of disappointed me because it
it got in the way of people interacting
because they had to start thinking kind
of more rationally and symbolically
rather than intuitively so I started
making these programs that there was
nothing there that but the interface is
just touch of course touch through a
mouse because that's that's what we had
in the 90s and they struggled with how
to distribute and exhibit this kind of
work on screens was an obvious way but
it's quite clunky because then you'd
have this little mouse coming out and a
button to erase then as pen tablet
computers started emerging I would show
that but then you were always nervous
you're going to lose that expensive pen
or someone's going to steal it and then
we had this idea when I was working at
interval research with a guy named Golan
Levin we thought wow wouldn't it be cool
if we took these kind of cool abstract
experiences and make a device like this
big and you know you could touch on the
back so put the touchscreen on the back
so your finger is an effort in the way
and you could just like trip out all day
long and
and just enjoy these these experiences
because experiences actually have a very
positive effect mentally on you you get
really really absorbed almost like in a
meditative state it's hard to really
convince anybody to meditate even though
it would be really good for you actually
but to make something cool that it that
brings people into like a more you know
relaxed open creative state so you know
in LA everybody has an idea for a
screenplay you know no matter what their
job is in this area everybody has an
idea for a business I'm sure everybody
here has one so this was our idea for
business and we started pitching it and
and nobody ended up funding it now
admittedly we didn't have the idea that
it should also be a phone and address
book it said that would have been a
really good idea anyway my time will
come ok so then this is a white people
started showing this kind of you know
what it started getting labeled digital
art you know and I was in a lot of art
shows and it shows stuff like this but I
never really had the heart these are
just laptops that you take apart and put
on a nice mount but I never really had
the heart to sell them because I knew
they were gonna break right everything
you know every laptop breaks within five
years so just waiting for some way to
distribute this kind of work and then of
course you know it arrived we found out
when the iPad and the iPhone came out so
I'll show you a couple of these I was
really surprised that that they were so
popular on this is an app called gravel
luxe and it's a way of drawing with
stars so you just kind of move with your
fingertips and it's like you're in
control of the universe right it's quite
fine on a really long time scale and you
know this got like six hundred thousand
downloads or something you know really
large amounts of downloads and it was
very encouraging because I like I said I
was always trying to convince people to
distribute this kind of work and now
once the App Store's came about then you
don't have to convince anybody that your
idea is good or what category it fits
into or if there's a market you can just
release it and if people like it they
they don't have to label it or or worry
about it being you know art or
entertainment or anything else this is
another app let me turn up the volume
okay this is an app called bubble heart
so this is a visual musical instrument
okay there you go there you go
so with this app I'll turn it up a
little bit it's a way of creating a kind
of animated painting and a melody at the
same time so as you draw on the screen
you create these points that follow your
finger tips and then this line between
the points gets played as if it's a harp
string so again it's hard to explain
what this is it's a combination of like
animation interactivity music if you
really dig in you can go and change the
scales so you can see how your melody
sounds in a chromatic scale rather than
a pentatonic so secretly this is
actually educational and people learn a
lot about scales because you can just
understand intuitively like what a blues
scale sounds like or this Hungarian
scale that that sounds very exotic to
Western ears
but it's very satisfying to be able to
instantly create a song right so all
these were based on natural phenomena
this is the this is the most realistic
one this is an app called the anta graph
where you draw with the ants actually so
let me we can do it you can try to draw
with this which is actually sort of fun
but what you see is like just as if
they're a real ants you know they do
they start to lose the head so it's a
lot of what I do actually is a little
bit frustrating because I've always this
idea of impermanence has always been
quite heavy in my mind so I like to make
things that are sort of destroying
themselves as they go so you kind of
have to keep engaged
but again this is secretly educational I
I feel like I would never put anything
in the educational category because the
word education sadly almost means boring
you know in our culture today for the
most part but you know I've given a
friend of mine who's who works at nature
nature publications said that you know
his son was using this program and asked
him you know what exactly am i drawing
like there's these ants but then they
stay on the trail and then his dad said
oh well ants lay down pheromone and
there's that it's an invisible chemical
and that's what you're doing you're
laying your painting at the same time
ants and pheromone so you know in terms
of education especially with you know
younger people to lead people to start
asking questions through through doing
something extremely fun and satisfying
is is probably more powerful way to
teach them to then you know a harshly
structured kind of curriculum more on
that later
so I actually though there was a big a
big time between all that screen-based
work which was basically my passion but
I never had any understanding of how to
distribute it I mean so much so that I
used to call them useless programs it
was kind of a defensive
I'm sure I think our Indian Dan was a
great mentor would look at this stuff
sometimes and he'd say like 2d is a
solved problem you know because we did
3d computer graphics I said no there's
actually a lot to do in two dimensions
you know because with 3d computer
graphics are kind of stuck in the
Renaissance with perspective but there's
so many other forms of expression in two
dimension too even now still to explore
with the computer so between that time
of the iPad and kind of giving up on
screen based work I started making these
installations gestural installations
this is one called boundary functions
it's the first one I made I think it's
one of the very first like gestural in
computer vision I guess I call them
computer vision graphic systems and it's
a floor that you walk on and it draws
lines between people and the lines form
I actually bet a lot of people know what
these diagrams are called right like in
this audience how many people know what
this diagrams come as they walk in a lot
yeah so these are called born eye
diagrams and diagrams have an enormous
amount of meaning when you look at them
in the physical world they're the
structure of bubbles is formed in the
forms of those diagrams space the
gravitational influence of stars dogs
even pee in these patterns believe it or
not and when people are moving through
space your personal space is described
as a Voronoi diagram the space that's
closer to you than to anybody else but
what I wanted to show is that you
actually don't have any when you're
alone see so when you walk onto this
floor alone nothing happens so it's a
pretty radical interactive interactive
experience because you can't experience
it alone there has to be more people
there and the more people enter the
better it is and that's always been my
point of view on body interactivity or
gestural interactivity is there another
word for this field I don't know I don't
know what you we still have quite a word
for headlines it's personal space this
basically is that I felt that if more
than one person can fit into an
experience than it should meaningfully
respond to them and ideally get better
the kind of write of the way one life
does if you
so that's the boundary functions the
other the other thing I found about this
is that it was actually a social
psychological experiment and it showed
the differences between cultures and how
we think about personal space so I first
showed this in Austria and Austria
Germany and I was really disappointed
because people just kind of grouped on
the edges and wouldn't for the most part
move on to this this stage so I actually
thought I'd failed it was really my
first work of interactive art like this
and I thought and you give up a lot of
control when you make anything
interactive and so I thought wow I've
really failed I thought people were
going to going to interact and during
the opening they did because it was so
crowded but for the most part people who
are kind of shy then I showed the same
piece in Japan and people behave
completely differently in Japan
strangers would come up to each other
would touch each other so they're doing
exactly what I hope for and so I
realized is that different cultures have
different points of view about personal
space and I started looking it up and
there's a field called proxemics it
turns out that studies this formally and
the whole field can be summarized
actually as a joke where they say if you
put an Italian and a Swede in a room
together
the Italian will start chasing the Swede
you know have you ever have you ever
talked like a Spanish person is how you
know you probably could do real science
experiments with this if you wanted to
so I also began working on these
interactive screens again mostly just
with you know homegrown code this was
before like open frameworks and Kinect
and things like that so this is again
one of the first pieces I made called
deep walls and it's a wall that absorbs
everything that happens in front of it
and plays it back now there's a there's
a really really important kind of HCI
lesson here and it seems super obvious
once you once you learn about it but if
you are kind of given the assignment to
make take some make a personal movie
generating application most of us would
take a kind of photobooth approach to it
where you give someone a pause a button
then there's a countdown three two one
then you have 30 seconds to make your
movie and then you
chip so what's wrong with that from my
point of view what's wrong with that is
it makes the computer in control a
person and what you really want is a
person in control of the computer so in
this case it's really really simple as
soon as the first person enters the
system starts recording and as soon as
the last person exits its it stops
recording and then that movie gets
pasted into one of sixteen rectangles so
relatively simple is certainly very
simple to implement you know if you ever
making something like this but a very
important lesson about like human
centered design the other thing is about
using a silhouette yeah well we have
let's the third thing is about behavior
I started to learn that these
experiences can actually change people's
behavior because if I ask to each
everyone in this room to come and do a
breakdance in front of everybody here I
don't think I'd have any takers but if
we turned on this piece almost all of
you would want to do it so you can
actually change people's people's
behavior and make them kind of more
outgoing more extroverted by rewarding
that somehow with the jet with the
interactivity especially this physical
gestural interactivity then the last
thing is so the last thing is about
shadows themselves
I found the shadow a really powerful
interface because there's all these
privacy concerns and also you know
vanity concerns about recording
somebody's image so the shadow solves
that very elegantly because you can
recognize your your silhouette and
other people's and your friends
silhouettes instantly and yet to
everybody else you're anonymous so it's
a very in an age that we have more and
more intrusions on our privacy eye
privacy may not even be a word in 10
years much like computer actually I
think both those words won't exist
anymore but this actually preserves your
privacy and yet lets you have an
individualized experience and I think
there's other solutions like that in
technology like I don't think every
answer has to be reveal more private
information about yourself this is a
piece where I started to try taking
taking interactivity into storytelling
there's this movie called shin on the
loo that begins like with an eye
all getting sliced any of you guys ever
ever see that there's a first surrealist
film by Salvador Dali and Louie buñuel
and so I started playing with this
medium a little bit more again this is
still a while ago like 2006 but the idea
was to take a vignette from that movie
and make it interactive so what what is
it what's it like to make an interactive
scene from a movie so here your your
body interacts with this just in two
simple ways one is by pushing away the
piano which makes this guy sort of
strain more and pulling it and the other
is if you touch the guy himself so if
you touch him for long enough something
happens so you see he starts to dissolve
into ants so I used the same ants I
think any of you who are programmers you
start to build up your little collection
of tricks right and somehow people
really I was would I was starting to I
was worried that you know this is more
of a like metaphorical piece but people
everybody understood it somehow this is
like an archetypal image of a man
pulling a piano everybody understands it
to kind of represent just you know the
nature of human existence very easy to
interpret and then I want to show one I
did do a lot of work like with haptics
and other kind of physical interfaces
and I want to show one example I know I
know you know I met Scott it's kind of I
used to talk about that stuff and this
is again a kind of extreme example of
seemingly useless device it's a little
console that you blow into and then it
takes your breath and it amplifies it
into this array of fans so turns like
breath into wind basically and take
something really personal and makes it
makes it public and the thing I was
getting after was that we always when we
say breath we almost always say my
breath you know my breath but it's
probably the last thing in the world
that's yours like like it or not we've
all breathed in each other already in
the last half hour and
breathes you out like we've we have
become part of each other over the
course the last half an hour so I wanted
to make a work of art that sort of
pushed at that idea that you know your
breath really isn't yours it's actually
this extremely public transaction and
when you make you know big physical
experiences like this you also get out
of it in some ways a much nicer
experience because you can see through
it you can walk around it you can sort
of choose how close to how far how tight
you engage and it's some probably better
suited to you know people's an
appropriate ception
then then just a screen on a wall but
it's very difficult and expensive making
this kind of stuff is sort of crazy
crazy project and never do again
but you know I mean that's what if you
want to say what's art it's it's you
know making something useless like it's
it's the only purpose of making objects
and experiences like a lot of the ones
I've showed you so far is to convey an
idea right it's sort of like writing a
book but you make it physical a lot of
people always ask what is art right and
so it's a little dangerous to go into
this territory but that would be the
definition I would I would advocate is
where you're creating an object or an
experience that's main purpose is to
communicate an idea rather than you know
a utilitarian purpose so so about seven
years ago I started a company and or I
guess there's only five years ago and we
started taking a lot of these
experiences and turning them into things
that we sell a lot of it came by demand
because I had museums interested in in
showing this kind of work this is one of
the ones that I that I really liked
called looking for light there's this
experiment where they ran the
electricity through this vat of
chemicals is not resembling the early
oceans and when you do you get these
amino acids spontaneously formed I think
the people who did the experiments
secretly hoped they'd start getting you
know eventually little creatures sort of
crawling out of this this VAT but you
only get the precursors to life so
there's still this kind of mystery of
how self-replicating their life emerged
and we explored that a little bit in
this piece you know people get struck by
lightning cell walls swung around them
protocells come up and then there's this
kind of magical mystical moment yeah and
don't quite know how and when cells
became self-replicating oh it's not
looking to life James Cameron's
revolution refill let me um
mute this so there we go
this is sort of taking it to the next
level we worked with James Cameron you
this is often the only video I show now
to explain what we do because it's you
know high production values but we did a
bunch of interactive experiences through
snare be interactive with James Cameron
to try to bring some of those
experiences to life through you know
interactive experiences I was a little
scared you know because James Cameron
has a kind of rough reputation but
actually he was amazed because you know
we took stuff
that wasn't interactive and and made it
work with today's technologies so these
kind of shadow walls this is one way you
relive a scene from that movie where the
wood sprites come and if you're moving
slowly they'll come and land directly on
you so this actually shows a little bit
more of how you can manipulate people's
behavior because it encourages going
slow so actually people would slow down
and be gentle this is an experience more
of a tablet experience where you can
create a scene from from Avatar so you
know James Cameron actually did this
virtual cinematography making his own
scenes through through digital
three-dimensional environments this lets
people do that themselves and compare
and then touch tables which are now a
kind of commodity there's still a lot of
subtlety I think to doing these right
and and again the emphasis me and my
company have is on social interaction
how can you encourage social interaction
with touch technologies and a big part
of is making it big enough and making
interfaces that are you know multi-touch
multi person so you can share
information move it back and forth and
we love using these tiles to that'm
instantly pop up a bunch of information
and then instantly take it away and then
finally this is like the future of
interaction even beyond connect are
these system I think you guys have some
really advanced ones like with vikon
there's a slightly lower end system but
where you walk in this space and then
you can become one of the characters
from Avatar and you know and you're
actually directed by James Cameron in
this case which is kind of funny because
then we had to direct James Cameron and
direct the director and to make this
exhibit I think you'll see a lot more of
this in the future because some I mean
people talk about goggles and immersive
reality but I love this experiences
where you nothing's on you it's
completely unencumbered and you just
walk into a space and you're magically
transported somewhere else and you know
this is the kind of direction we're
taking this kind of work towards you
know bigger spectacular experiences I
think as movie theaters die which they
will over the last next few years you
might start seeing stuff like this
popping up in them which is kind of
excites me because you know my career
sort of hit a wall because who want to
tell stories with this medium but
there's no like theater to go
and experienced it yet so now to take a
little a little alternate tour this is a
this is some work we did back in the day
this we want to hear so again this was
kind of work that that didn't really
have a distribution medium we were this
is in the 90s when was working at
interval research and we were so excited
by Pro Tools which is a new way of
making music like without instruments
just digital music video games which had
this new form of like incredible
controller and then DJ culture which was
again a way of you know non musicians
creating new forms of music so we mashed
all that up and started creating these
kind of interfaces where you could
create music again as a total amateur
you just play something that's like a
game and yet it has the output is a song
or a loop so here we're particularly
inspired by you know electronica and
that kind of music so again how do you
distribute this we kind of had to wait
you know about about um 15 years or so
until the iPad came out and now you know
this is available it's called
oscilloscope it's available in the App
Store
I'm not going to demo it for lack of
time but you know the same experience
sort of packaged and now distributable
you don't have to convince like a game
game distributor to take it on so
something interest because of all this
app store work that I started putting
out there on it got the interest of one
of someone that I was a big fan of Bjork
I love this picture because she's sort
of looking at me like I'm like the crazy
one in here
and she has this that's a beautiful
dress she has it's a spliced evening
gown in a mini dress like this is just
sewn together and it turned out that her
doctor she had a project that she had
started and she realized really really
early on that the album is dead and she
wanted to release her new her new work
of music feature like worth of music as
it as something else and something
interactive and the project's called
biophilia and her her first six album
said Bjork produced were more about her
her experiences in her life emotional
experiences the kind of stories you know
you hear a lot of people singing about
so for her seventh album she decided she
wanted to do something totally different
and so the subject matter she took
outside of her own life was everything
else in the whole universe so every
single song has something to do with
natural phenomena and something to do
with music music ecology and something
to do with interactivity and she was
looking for different ways to express
this at first she was thinking about a
touring exhibition than an IMAX movie
that Michel Gondry would direct luckily
he got busy and Green Hornet reshoots
and said this is what we made instead
which was an app so this is Biophilia it
begins in this kind of galaxy that's the
album cover let me show you what it
looks like when you first launch it so
you recognize David organism to the
greatest red giant floating in the
farthest realm of the universe with
biophilia comes a restless curiosity an
urge to investigate and discover the
elusive places where we meet nature
where she plays on our senses with
colors and forms perfumes and smells the
taste and touch of salty wind on the
tongue but much of nature is hidden from
us that we can neither see nor touch
like the one phenomenon that can be said
to move us more than any other in our
daily lives
sound sound harnessed by human beings
delivered with generosity and emotion is
what we call music so I like to go up to
that spot because I love that definition
that music is sound plus generosity and
I think it's a good idea for any of us
to think of our job as something plus
generosity it's really really kind of
helps you and keeps you in a relatively
positive mood so the way this album
works is that this galaxy has a number
of constellations 10 and each of them is
one of the songs so crystalline was the
first app that was released the first
single now eat there are a number of
common elements to every song and then
there's a unique element so the some of
the common elements or ways of looking
at the music itself so here you see a
traditional musical score albeit a
really beautiful one so this is kind of
like a karaoke it's missing the vocal
track so you can sing along with it if
you like again everything here is
totally interactive none of this is a
movie so you can you know scroll
backwards and forwards and find find and
understand the music and again this is
really I think for anyone who's done any
music at all it's it's almost like a
shivers you get when you see music that
you really love for the first time in a
notational form and you realize oh
that's the same way Bach made music or
Beethoven made music you can also turn
off the the music track and get a
metronome and then you could put this on
your music stand and you could play the
music with the piano of Luther and so on
and if you go on YouTube people actually
doing this and making their own versions
of a Bjork songs
now Bjork's classically-trained but
actually she was relatively impatient
and frustrated with the way they teach
western music which you know like a lot
of topics the way they're taught it
often deadens them so we did another
form of visualization so we created
these abstract animated scores so here
actually you can see the musical
structure much better than in western
music right and we separate the
different instruments with color the
vocal tract is blue and again you can
you can zoom backwards and forwards now
and to bring home the fact that this is
actually useful it's not just a
beautiful visualization Bjork and the
other artists actually use this
visualization on on stage as a
teleprompter to guide them through the
music as they're performing in
preference to any other way okay so now
the main event in each app is some kind
of unique experience everyone still hear
me okay that's Andres okay great so with
crystalline what you can do is twist and
catch crystals or scrape crystals off
the side of this these tunnels and then
as you get to the end of a tunnel you
can choose another one and what happens
is you're you're choosing a different
part of the song to go into
so would this the natural aspect of this
is obviously crystals the musical aspect
is about musical structure you can
actually restructure this song in 10,000
different ways and then interactively
it's the most like a game of any of the
experiences in here and again you might
ask why this why does it look like this
and not another way part of it is a kind
of you know nostalgia for games like
tempest and stuff in the in the 80s but
the idea actually came from Bjork
because she said then she listens to
music she actually sees images like this
in her head if she has a kind of mild
synesthesia where she sees a tunnel
where the number of sides relate to the
kind of tempo or the beat structure and
then that changes as it goes through
different parts of the song okay so
let's take another one virus is
something completely different so this
app is like more like a music video but
an interactive music video so the song
plays and everything here is interactive
you can grab cells and move them around
by dragging them and then viruses are
coming in as this song starts to play so
the viruses are attacking the central
cell and the song itself is a kind of
hum instead of a femme fatale it's like
a virus fatale song the story of virus
is loving a cell so much that they need
to kill it
so you see the cells sing along with it
with the chorus and handsome so so this
is it feels like a game and you can
actually take the viruses and fling them
away and start to protect the central
cell but if you do you get stuck two
verses in and you go into an
instrumental holding pattern so it's a
game that you actually have to lose in
order to win you have to let the cell
get killed infected and then killed in
order to hear the whole song it's also
it's also a way to stretch out a song
too because you can stretch out the
parts that you like and turn five-minute
song into a 15-minute song so there
there are a lot of different ways of
making interactive music you know and we
were lucky because we got to explore it
in the 90s at interval and now there's
this whole sort of vocabulary to draw in
and in apps like this so here's one
that's again also completely different
this is Thunderbolt and in this app you
can how to make little spikes if you
touch if you drag you can draw with
lightning and if you put your two finger
two fingers down you create arpeggios so
if your fingers are close you create one
note and then two notes three notes four
notes
so now paggio is just a sequence of
notes for any of you that don't know
that and you can increase the tempo by
moving up and then decrease it by moving
down and then you can also make non
sequential arpeggios by putting three
four or five fingers out
so that up is more like an instrument
but again it's a very idiosyncratic kind
of personal instrument and I think
that's what's really exciting about the
tablet is completely reinventing music
as a new audio visual medium it's a
moment that's almost like the birth of
opera or the birth of cinema that's will
greatly transform music if you show you
one last one it's you can't go through
them all but this is an app this one was
written by Max Weis office a great young
programmer and in this app you can
change notes so it's a kind of sequencer
like a harp sequencer you move these
pearls to determine which note plays and
in the phase of the moon here determines
how much spinal fluid is coming up from
the earth okay so really interesting
metaphor about the connection of like
our body to the planets which there
really is right and then if you make the
moon brighter and brighter you play more
and more notes now that almost sounded
like the sound of silence there you go
or you can load your song and play that
so you can dive into that yourselves if
you have an iPhone or an iPad sometime
so we were talking a little bit about
the album and the death of the album now
actually not I bet not that many people
in the audience ever even bought an LP
and brought it on how many people come
from the age of the LP have brought an
LP home okay yeah it's like a minority
in this group so let me tell you about
that experience you you buy this thing
you wouldn't know what it sounds like
you just buy this 12-inch 12 by 12 inch
objects mostly based on the way it looks
and you bring it home you'd open it up
and you'd go to your turntable and and
put it down
and for some reason often you'd be on
the floor like it was almost like a holy
moment when you got your got your album
and you'd be stuck there and you'd be
listening to album while you decipher
the artwork and read the liner notes and
the lyrics so what I call this is the
falling in love period with music this
is when people this is the time when
you're completely absorbed all your
senses with music and we've lost that
now in the ages of mp3 now I'd say we
have more like a casual relationship
with music kind of like hook up with
music here and there but but we've
missed that that falling in love stage
and it's not inevitable actually that
all media goes towards like shorter and
shorter forms and more and more
distracted I think with the iPad we're
seeing this blossoming again of
long-term deep engagement and it's
possible with you know many other media
so to kind of its kind of bring that you
know what I might skip this is such an
interesting thing but we're running a
little bit well I don't know how long do
we have till 2:00 till 2:00 okay
that's worth talking that so so probably
a lot of you guys know who this is John
McCarthy there's this great I bet I bet
you guys read this there's his article
called a fight to win the future
computers versus humans by John Markoff
last year in the New York Times and he
was talking about this two fundamentally
different views of Technology so John
McCarthy coined the term AI I'm Tara her
evening knows at home to him and to put
it simply and bluntly at least you know
in terms of like the way this essay was
written is that there was an idea that
computer
would replace human intelligence in some
form or another and there was another
point of view that was championed by
someone named Doug Engelbart which was
the point of view that computers could
augment human creativity and
communication and I think a lot of you
might have seen if you haven't looked it
up on YouTube he did this thing called
the mother of all demos which is this
incredible video where he demonstrates
the mouse word processing hypertext
teleconferencing the internet like
everything at once just all invented you
know here and here in the bay here in
the the peninsula so what does that turn
into today you know last year it was
yeah I guess was last year we saw Watson
you know the first time that a computer
beat humans in jeopardy and the thing
about Watson is that if you did any of
you watch that did some of you watch
that game so the sad thing about Watson
is that he can beat the pants off of all
these guys but he doesn't even know he's
standing next to people and that they're
making fun of him right it's it's a very
it's a it's a weak view of intelligence
right and then of course this is the the
kind of crystallization of this
alternate view of the role of Technology
in human life is Steve Jobs that someone
who's genuinely driven by a mission to
expand humanity's capacity to create and
communicate so the question of course is
you know which one do you choose the red
pill or the blue pill right which which
which team are you on of course we're
driving full steam ahead with both and
mostly in the consumer side we're
driving massively fast with the Steve
Jobs model but I think in the military
side and you know some of the other
things going on in the world and data
analytics that other side is also
driving full steam ahead I don't know if
they're at odds with each other or or
one will win or lose but I wanted to
bring up that point of view and
obviously point towards replacing human
intelligence with kind of knowledge
processing is sort of single-minded in
literal but augmenting human
intelligence has almost a kind of
infinite infinite ways of expressing
itself and I
that's what's so exciting about the
AppStore I wanted to show you know as my
final side these these two examples that
really excite me because these are two
of the best-selling apps in the App
Store besides games okay one is on the
left they're both by touch press
whoo-hoo also worked on that biophilia
project the one on the left is called
the element it's made like ten million
dollars in the App Store okay who would
have thought that one of the best
selling apps in App Store it was about
you no matter it's about the the you
know the elements of our of our universe
and how they make things up so like I
was saying before the idea of a product
has exploded where you could have you
know works of art social media etc the
other example is the wasteland okay
again best-selling app about TS Eliot
poetry but because it's done so
beautifully and so well it just sits up
there you know and it's in the top ten
and keep selling and selling and selling
and what what's interesting I think
about the where we are in technology
right now is that programs like
Photoshop or Excel were inevitable in
some sense like these things would have
happened somebody would have made them
if if these people hadn't but program
like the elements or with a wasteland of
Biophilia or even Twitter and Instagram
they're not inevitable and there's
something a guy named jonathan harris
would be an amazing speaker for this
series actually he did this thing called
we feel fine and a lot of very very
human social interfaces sort of
alternatives to facebook and what he
said is that these computers that we're
putting on our bodies are rehearsals for
when computers get connected to our
minds our brains and that's going to
happen quite likely you know the next 10
or 15 years and what that really struck
me and i think that we're in a
particular moment especially now in
these next like 3 to 5 years where we
actually can very very small changes in
the app store for example or things like
the app store could have huge effects on
the future of humanity and its
relationship to computers because you
see how a tiny idea by a couple of
people can explode and get a hundred
million users very quickly so i think
that's sort of how i wanna close is say
like we actually have a choice like the
future isn't inevitable especially with
the the doors of distribution totally
flung wide open by you know App Store
Amazon eBay things like that so it's
actually possible to choose futures
where concentration is encouraged where
you know long-term engagement like
meaningful communication happen and it's
also possible to encourage a future of
you know distraction meaninglessness
triviality and I just like to encourage
people to sort of open your minds to you
know the latter model because each of us
here could you know create a company or
a product or just an idea that massively
affects the future that we all live in
you know 15 to 20 years from now so
that's like conclusion I think is it
maybe a tiny bit of time for questions
a couple minutes yeah Oh over there so
at this inspiring table and you started
out with how you're disappointed with
the Macintosh having a desktop metaphor
and I'd be like a lot of the reasons why
we have programs to choose desktop
metaphysis because we have tools which
ask programmers to use it as dogma dry
yeah elements doneness you know just
clear everything off screen and what is
the thing that you would change with the
tools well the thing is it's it's
already done like watch I mean do you
see what happens when you like switch to
another app like this you see what
happens on Oh does it show that ham in
there yeah I mean you see what happens
on an on and I pad when you switch
between things as it actually uses that
language of cinema so it already exists
in iOS and I think it will be adopted
you know by the other platforms where
the I think the biggest thing is using
the whole screen like it's just like
television or movies you don't there's
no point to be distracted by like your
email underneath a picture you know and
underneath the alarm and and so on so I
think getting rid of like the windowing
desktop interfaces is very very positive
for human attention like people are
designed to focus on one thing at once
and you know a messy desk is not you
know the most stimulating or the most
effective way for many people into work
so I think moving to these you know film
based interfaces is is the answer in a
nutshell but we already have it I mean
if you study iOS especially on the iPad
I think they've done it really well and
you know wipes dissolves cuts it's the
language of cinema get up get like a
basic cinema but yeah to learn some of
that you know from another point of view
yeah sort of a big question about with
respect to the music apps the
relationship between modes of aesthetic
experience and gameplay so gameplay can
sometimes encourage sort of goal
orientation and you just I figured out I
solved which is different than
receiving the work of art yeah yeah well
I mean the thing about games is they are
really addictive but it's sort of it's
sort of the easy way out like sometimes
I say you know interactivity in games is
kind of like music and marches like
imagine that all music was marches right
like we all like a march from time to
time
but but there's way more to music than
marches and there's way more to
interactivity than games so it's just
that it's easy if you give someone it's
like it's like sugar yeah you know we're
soap opera-like cliffhangers like
there's there's super stimuli for human
beings that that are easy ways to a dick
people but the things we most enjoy in
life aren't aren't the addictive once we
actually addiction isn't pleasant at all
right like when you finally get the
thing you've been dying for all day with
like a piece of cake or whatever you're
actually not feeling that good what
you're feeling is the absence of the
pain of not having it right like it's
very different than than a sincere form
of like satisfaction so like they often
say like happiness is different than
pleasure and that's what I'd say like
there's a way to make interfaces that
make you happy instead of making you
feel pleasure anything else yeah do do
all your own sound and graphics
no there's there's tons of people I mean
it's I have like 30 30 person staff and
then you know collaborate with lots of
people the Bjork project alone was about
30 people
I didn't properly credit there's a
massive amount of people and we produced
the project and we made you know several
of the individual apps you have tons of
collaborators yeah and the proliferation
of them as a media yeah so that's a huge
issue and something I've been thinking
about a lot in the last two years
because they are wildly expensive but
you know that that presents an
opportunity you know and that's
something I'm looking at with our
companies is how could you make
platforms that make this more of a an
easily adoptable and spreadable
experience then you know something that
costs like hundreds of thousands of
dollars to produce so it's just like any
media Mick there's opportunities to
disrupt disrupt it yeah you know they're
all they're all wrapped into the one big
app some she's doing that now with some
new stuff like the first part of the
product we did was you know with
biophilia was more like she had a bunch
of ideas you know and we sort of turned
them into interactivity and images but
she is doing that now more as make we're
making some new stuff and she's using it
to to create songs that fall out of the
interfaces so can go both ways
anything else
you